sehr schön die habe ich das gemacht
die rache habe ich gemacht ganz einfach
krachen und excel services und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video heute
spielen wir minecraft sky wars mit dem
ok alles klar
markowski wars mit der wii hd am start
mit wem und mit dem very mit dem der
brief ist wahrscheinlich ich weiß es
nicht aber zwei türen der mitte
doch ankara ich unter dem alter hatte
ich die auch bolls ich muss sagen jüngst
ich habe extrem viel holz also wenn
jemand heute haben will
ich habe extrem viel skill wir sind
nicht zu dritt einer lebt noch neben ihm
agieren doch echt also hat mir doch zwei
gegner wehren uns hier eigentlich mehr
oder weniger so eine runde für uns doch
nicht so nach bevor in die mitte kommen
wahnsinnig wird natürlich ja selbst zu
stellen haben wir wollen ja nicht dass
man einfach mal ankommen auf wen sollte
zuerst gehen von euch wollen wir auf
mich man aufnahmen
erst überweisen ein wird hill wo sie
erste auftritte wie er dort
wahrscheinlich braucht er sie auch
kräftig in die mitte zurück
das kann hier neben mir so hat sich die
frage wer als nächstes die base mit
übernimmt wenn ich sauer das ist der
andere was ich bau mir mal so eine ganz
kleine festung dass ich gar nicht
runterfahren kann ich bin nämlich gerade
ihr vorhaben schon mal aufgenommen
einfach runter gefallen
wir haben wir schon ein paar versuche so
kann man brokaw mich an eine million der
stifter wieder diesmal stelle ich nicht
verstand ich brauche ich erstmal safe
einmal so ich habe wieder meine stärke
porschen spiel das make it übrigens
leute da hat man den untereinander
stärke porsche und ich sage wenn er hier
ein drop dann hab ich den das eigentlich
mega unfair wenn man kann gar nicht
gewinnen wenn du so einen scheiß stärke
forschen doch man kann mich runter
schlagen und man kann vieles argument
habe ich habe überhaupt kein kind das
ist gar kein kind da geht ja klar stelle
mich jetzt hier in die wand wenn er ein
jump und ich warte jetzt nur noch dass
er rein springt dann gebe ich ja beide
branchen zu einem möglichen weg hat
keine chance
sage ich aber kommt er er baut sich zu
die rüberkam warum tut mir ja oder in
die andere richtung verstehe es nicht
oder kommt jetzt doch er komponiert das
wird richtig eklig alter na komm
jetzt soll ich noch machen deutlich an
alter schwede es ist richtig richtig
intense gerade deshalb in fukushima ist
helfen könnte sein könnten die
erschwerten wird kritisch ist eine
langsamkeit ok radio roboter neid jetzt
habe ich uns beiden stärke gegeben aber
er weiß es nicht weise die es dauern
desto stärker vor eine klatsche ich hab
ihn okay so belastet das finale
jetzt geht es nur noch ums beide usa
eigentlich ist der typ mann das ist
nicht dein ernst ich wusste einfach dass
du genau die somit direkt hinter mir
stehst alter schwede junge durch die
ganze zeit auf ihn gekommen ich habe so
von unten und also komplett weit unten
einfach zu dass einfach ich wusste
diesem entweder zu leise was über star
wars
ich wusste dass ich wusste sie wusste
ich was du leute runde nummer zwei jetzt
muss man mal gucken was ein bisschen
skill demonstrieren nachdem nochmal und
dem kreis ist ja auf die übelste art und
weise reingelegt hat es ja gar nicht man
ja ich kann man einfach von hinten muss
jetzt noch der ein oder gibt es noch
keine klare kiste
ich bin der alte als ob da ist ja
wahrscheinlich morgen deutschland oder
ändert werde in laterne lag da ist er
weg sicher sehr schön wie habe ich das
gemacht
die rache habe ich gemacht ganz einfach
reifer und excel so matthias guck mal
ich hatte gar keine lust hat sich da
natürlich bei ihnen gezeigten dem moment
herrscht ja niemand irgendwas mit stimmt
in den silent deshalb soll jetzt wird
gefeiert wird euch gefallen ihr könnt
jetzt live kommentieren hinkommt einer
rum whisky bock mich da an zweiten mal
in der mitte glaube ich glaube niemand
hat ihm die arbeit wird aufpassen ich
würde ich sagen aber eine angabe
scheinlich schon wussten aber ich könnte
auch eine woche hatte jetzt angriff ist
nice weiter machst du noch deine stärke
drin
nee ich hab noch gar nicht benutzen
können klar wird warum hasst mich ebenso
schnell weg vom hirsch wertiger drei
jetzt gras karas mit dir schwer zwar
jetzt schnell weg
hoffentlich wird jetzt direkt neben ihr
niemals hat auf jeden fall der angel
ich frage ist nur wie lange ich will
noch eins mit auf den weg ich fahre nur
ob der andere als auch schon mein base
ist ich weiß in der ds eine base
integrieren großen ich glaub der tochter
und nicht den angesehen sagt die junge
junge junge junge
es ist auf jeden fall intense ich weiß
ja du bist jetzt eigentlich so dürfte
ziemlich die arschkarte und ja ich hab
jetzt ein ziemliches problem ich muss
auf eingehen von den beiden
ich würde fast sagen all ihren stärken
und regeneration
ja ich mir den den swiss zocker will ich
sagen ja
das aber gefährlich er schmeckt den weg
in die luft springen jetzt einfach
schnell zum anderen regeneration reine
hast du dir von herzen
sondern easyjet ist auf der insel und
rechtzeitig die stärkeren ball hat easy
sehr stellt judith weck natürlich der
guardian drin stärkeren die mädchen habe
ich wiederkomme aufprall gegeben die
stärke kurz bevor er rein kommt und
jetzt gucken wir mal was sie so alles
machen die anderen beiden die falten die
feierten auch und ich will euch meine
stärke nutzen ich hab noch 130 in der
stärke porsche durch die stärke vor
schluss war ich ganz gewiss nutzen
könnte so swift zocker was geht bei dir
bald ich würde stärke noch laufe ja ich
weiß aber ich weiß auch nicht was der da
drüben vorhalten das bau- und einfach
ein bisschen darüber
weiter hat er hatte tnt ist der dom
vielleicht hat das kind wurde sofort für
tnt also wenn du keine blöcke beherzt
brauchst du irgendwann sagt das sehr
schön einmal von unten weg geknallt sei
jetzt haben wir den hier da oben weg mit
dir war wer jetzt auch noch runter
gefallen du wirst der king junge ja
dafür da wird es leider nicht gereicht
aber bin ich auch so glaubt ja weniger
mit mir spielen
dort notieren heute vor ort und ich habe
keine ahnung wer gegen den kitt womit
man keine explosion scheiben fact
glauben nicht vermachte wasser 112
sekunden stärke lauf lauf obwohl er ich
würde auch einfach mal rein gehen
ehrlich gesagt ja aber eigentlich
einstellung ich hab mich haben ich habe
jetzt habe ich mittlerweile jetzt habe
ich locker ja sehr schön
perfekt also machte check die beiden ab
diese beschreibung verlinkt dank fürs
dabeisein genau der blackline von
panther 15 uhr also am ersten 12 15 uhr
das video später sehen wollen das was
von uns war einfach gut und